- Well, Tom, I didn't know this,
but Julliard, you went to
Julliard just like Viola Davis.
- Yes.
- Who by the way, is
so scary in this movie.
Like and that is like-
How she said the word 'dull,'
I almost peed my pants.
- Yeah.
I was like, don't piss her off.
Anyway, but I didn't
know that you both went-
I knew she went there, but I
didn't know you did as well.
That's amazing, did y'all-
- Yeah, we weren't in the same class.
- Obviously.
- Yeah.
- Different generations.
But I didn't know that
you both went there.
I just thought that was
kind of a cool thing.
That's an amazing thing that you,
you did in your life that
you both have in common.
- Yeah.
I mean, it's the reason
I ended up in New York,
which is, I'm very grateful for.
- Yeah.
- But it's kind of how we bonded on set,
was like talking about, you
know, our shared stories
and weirdly found out that we have like
some of the same teachers years apart
that have stayed there.
- I was gonna ask that.
- Yeah, one of our
movement coaches in school
was the same teacher,
so he'd just been, they're
his entire existence, I guess.
- Wow, that's really cool.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
Did you ever actually get
to meet Jennifer Lawrence?
Anybody hear-
- I did.
I think I'm the only one.
I did.
- Oh Okay.
- We were at the Paris Fashion
Week for the Dior show.
Only a couple weeks ago.
- Yeah.
- And I didn't want to be
weird and I was just kind of
psyching myself up to talk to her
and she was so unbelievably kind.
And in that clip she's actually saying,
let's do another photo
where I'm strangling you,
saying "You'll never take my part."
(audience laughing)
And that is exactly
what I wanted from her.
- I love that about her.
She seems like the same
offscreen and onscreen.
- Truly.
- It's amazing.
That's the cool thing, like working with,
there's so many people in this
movie too that, like Viola,
that's just amazing to
be able to work with too.
Do you get nervous in scenes
with people like that?
- Yeah, I mean, especially
when you see Viola's costume,
when she comes in with that fake eye.
- Dude, she scared the-
- Everything, right?
It's kind of terrifying.
But then she breaks for lunch
and she's the funniest
person in the world.
We were just with her this
morning and she's like so funny.
- She's so funny.
- She like immediately cuts
through any intimidation.
She's great.
- Oh I love that.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.